when could we get new Stargate actually
on our screen
it's a simple question with a slightly
complicated answer welcome to Sidetrack
here Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so as you know we've been following the
plans for a new Stargate series or movie
probably a movie very very closely and I
get asked all the time when do we
actually think we could get it on our
screens well it looks at the moment like
the plan is to do a straight to cinema
movie
So after talking to a couple of the
people I do get to speak to and looking
at previous projects I've been able to
figure out a very rough timeline for how
long we can expect the movie to actually
get made and then actually appear on our
Cinema screens I've had to try to
extrapolate where we are in the process
currently with Stargate and I have had a
few things confirmed about exactly where
we are so let's get into it when will
the Stargate movie actually appear in
theaters first of all there are
basically four stages for producing a
straighter Cinema movie development is
the first stage and that's the one stage
that we really cannot put a time frame
on sometimes it can be weeks or even
months sometimes it can be years
sometimes a script could knock around
Hollywood for decades and this is all
considered that development period we
all know about movies or TV shows that
get stuck in development hell and end up
going through director after director or
you know rewrites and rewrites we all
know those horror stories so it's
impossible to really tell how long that
period could be so is the Stargate movie
still in that development period well
we've heard a few rumors about sets
potentially being built and scripts
actually being written we've heard
rumors about development for over 12
months I can now tell you unfortunately
I can't share details on this because
the source isn't able to share this
publicly yet but I can confirm to you
actually that we are are out of that
development period that Amazon now
consider the Stargate movie to be in
pre-production now I'm going to put a
little caveat on that immediately
strikes have caused a lot of doubt we
don't really know exactly where the dice
are going to land at the end of this
strike period so everything is still up
in the air but the project as it was
planned early this year around March was
for the Cinematic movie it was for that
movie to appear on our screens by the
end of 2024 or early 2025 and principal
photography was supposed to have started
around now
so that was the original plan
who knows what's going to happen when we
actually get out of this strike period
though so technically we are in this
pre-production period so how long does
pre-production normally take well it is
roughly a six-month period they have to
build sets they have to hire crew they
have to Scout and then arrange for
locations for filming and they have to
do a lot of early CGI work now again we
believe and we have pretty strong
groomers and I've been able to confirm
little bits that actually early CGI work
was pre-arranged for um August September
this year
that sets have started to get built and
a lot of that work is continuing even
today but really at a snail's pace
according to one source and this bit
isn't confirmed but according to One
Source actually sets and things are
still being worked on but just very
slowly they've basically stripped the
crew down to the bare minimum they have
absolutely no idea how long these
strikes are going to go on for they want
the work to continue but they don't want
to spend an absolute fortune and what
they really don't want to do is have
very large sets sat empty waiting for
months because then that actually costs
more money you've got storage costs
you've got maintenance costs so on and
so on so they're allowing certain work
to carry on they want the development
Etc to continue but they do not want to
go too far too fast and actually end up
wasting millions of dollars so we
believe the movie is in that
pre-production period as I say that
pre-production period normally lasts
around six months but then we get into
principal photography so principal
photography can be even just few weeks
of smaller movies or it can be several
months the source I spoke to recently
says principal photography for this
movie is expected to be something like
four to six months so he says for a
sci-fi movie of this sort of size that's
kind of standard it really does depend
on the budget it really does depend on
whether there are lots of locations in
lots of different parts of the world
things like that for example because
moving the actual
um crew Etc around is time consuming all
of these things do impact the time scale
but we can expect four to six months
roughly when we get into the
post-production period that really can
take sometimes just a few months if it's
amazing have no big CGI it really is
just sort of editing the movie sort of
putting it together and then sending it
out but if there is CGI Etc or if you
need reshoots and things like this which
is becoming more and more common for
cinematic movies and really anything
then this period can take say 12 months
the post-production for Who Framed Roger
Rabbit for example took 14 months
because there was an awful lot of
drawing to be done
so the post-production period on average
for a big budget sci-fi movie we can
expect to be something like 12 months so
if we put all this together when could
we expect the new Stargate movie to
actually appear in theaters
well this plan of the end of 2024 or
early 2025 has been blown out of the
water by the strikes the problem isn't
just though that actually we've already
been on strike for a couple of months
the problem is that Amazon have had to
shut most of the development except to
work down and it's going to take a
couple of months to restart and get
going again at full strength of very
least you need to get crew back on set
you need to get all of these things back
like food trucks and things just
practical stuff like that we'll take a
little bit of time to get going so even
if the strikes ended today work wouldn't
really start again probably until well
nearly Christmas principal photography
won't then probably start till the
spring so the delay is massive and it
means that that pre-production period
has gone from six months to maybe 12.
so all of a sudden we will not be
looking at the end of 2024 early 2025 we
may actually be looking at two years
from the point the strikes end so if the
strikes ended today we would be looking
at late summer 2025 maybe early 2026.
however a lot of experts are saying the
strike might not end until after
Christmas maybe even as late as next
spring if that's the case we will be
looking at Spring 2026 as the earliest
date for us to get the new Stargate
movie
now that's quite a long time but we'll
have lots of Juicy tidbits to discuss
along the way once we get into principal
photography that's really when a lot of
set leaks and things should start
appearing and we'll have loads of things
to talk about but there is also an
interesting possibility
what if Amazon do change their minds
what if Amazon do switch the development
work from a movie to a TV series now
that would change things slightly
but not as much as it used to back in
the day you know when we were getting 22
Episodes of Star Trek sg1 or whatever we
could get from
principal filming to actually on our
screens in three to four months because
they were doing a series a year they
didn't have time to spend six months on
pre-production Etc they had to crack on
they had to get it done a lot of the
times scripts are being written the day
before those episodes then got filmed
so it was very much by the seat of your
pants
however
TV series if that's what Amazon then
decided to do would be made in a very
similar way to a movie because that's
how straighter streaming services and
particularly make series nowadays they
make them like 10 hour movies now it
does mean though that Amazon could
switch a lot of the development they've
already done like even the building sets
Etc to the movie Very simply all of that
stuff wouldn't get wasted and it
probably would save a bit of time off
this time frame that we're talking about
for a cinematic movie all of a sudden
they would be able to cut a few Corners
they wouldn't have to be quite so much
work done to make the sets absolutely
sort of HD quality because at the end of
the day a cinema quality movie has to go
that next step it has to be just that
little bit more detailed higher quality
you know HD on a massive screen will
show up little problems with the CGI so
a TV show can cut few of those corners
and can be made just that little bit
quicker but we'd still be looking at
probably 18 months from when the strikes
end instead of two years for a cinema
movie so we would still be looking at
even if the strikes ended today maybe
the spring of 2025
now I know a lot of you guys are not
going to be very happy about a lot of
these dates it's too long it's already
been going on too long but when a TV
production company is spending a hundred
two hundred million dollars on a project
things do take time
but let's be honest
hopefully anyway it's going to be worth
the wait
so I will keep you informed as we go
along we will keep talking about
Stargate we will keep banging the drum
because we desperately want this show to
be on our screens or the movie to be on
the big screen as quickly as possible we
want Brad Wright to be involved hashtag
we want Brad we want all of these things
but we will not get it if we don't
demand it
so please like subscribe and share this
video where you can we need as many
Stargate fans to be talking about this
is humanly possible
and that's the way we'll get the project
hopefully in the end that we actually
want
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month you get to
support the channel and see those videos
without the adverts also you can go to
our dedicated website
sidetrack.co.uk where we do stories
related to most of these videos and we
try to put a little bit more meat on the
bones for you to think about so please
go and check that out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign